uh let's see what else we've got here
let's go to our caller
from the 937 area code caller from 937
what's your name where are you calling
from
uh is this me yes it is
oh my gosh that's awesome uh hi my
name's austin
i'm from uh flavortown ohio all right
and austin please just keep the phone a
little further from your mouth because
you're coming in a little hot and it's
crunching
all right sorry is that better oh my god
that's so much better thank you
okay uh so my question
is um that
so i'm kind of i've been talking with my
friends a lot about this and i just
wanted to get your opinion on it
um i am really
concerned about all this malpractice
that's going to be happening with
the postal service yes and i'm worried
about voting in uh voting in by mail
so i feel like i have to vote in person
but i also am concerned about you know
voting in person because of coronavirus
of
well obvious reasons yeah right
so i guess like
where should my priorities lie well okay
so he basically this is going to be a
call that a lot of people have to make
there are many people who rightly would
would as i've said crawl over broken
glass to vote in november
so you are going to have to make the
call can you get
as i've said before they can slow down
the mail
but right now it doesn't seem like
they're just going to throw
absentee ballots in the trash so if you
can get your ballot
several weeks before the election and
mail it in even if they delay
the ballots three four five days it's
going to get there
and by all reasonable estimates it's
going to be counted so that's number one
right the the
they're they're going to try but if you
can get your absentee ballot in and send
it in early as i'm going to be doing
here in massachusetts you really
shouldn't have a problem
when it comes to voting in person listen
the situations are dramatically
different in different precincts where
some places you you put a mask on and
you go in and you're in and out in 10
minutes and it's no big deal
in other places you could be waiting for
hours surrounded by people mostly not
wearing masks and that's a real concern
and you it's going to be a very
individual decision unfortunately
there's no there's no way i can tell you
what makes sense but
i i am confident that you should be able
to vote and have your vote counted i'm
relatively certain that you will be able
to achieve that
that makes sense yeah
uh yeah thanks david all right thank you
yes a concern that many people have and
is going to be a very big deal going
forward